Senator Holly thanks so much for joining
us I know you've just come out of the
Senate chamber so we're seeing reports
today and I know it's the other side of
the aisle but I've either stood in your
perspective that there are a number of
Democrats joe Manchin of West Virginia
Kyrsten Sinema of Arizona among them who
are considering a vote to acquit do you
think that's true a and B if it is what
does it tell us well I think it's very
possible Tucker and I think what it
tells me this they just don't have a
case I mean I think we're really
watching here with the questioning
tonight the Democrats case just fall
apart I just came from the floor we're
in recess here and Adams shift is set on
the floor that this case is all about
bribery it's about extortion that's
what's going on here but the house
didn't charge bribery or extortion they
didn't allege any of that in their
articles of impeachment I mean it leaves
you wondering like why are we here
exactly they don't even know and so I
think that Democrats are sensing that
and I wouldn't be surprised if we picked
up some votes so you're sitting unites
tennard's united states senator just
spent all day at the impeachment trial
if you're asking the big questions like
why are we here that's deeply revealing
let me ask you yeah and this is
hypothetical but if it turns out the
Democrats don't hold the line some vote
to acquit what will they say at that
point I wonder as a part well again well
I think they're gonna just have to admit
that listen that this was ill-advised
from the beginning what it really has
been is a partisan attempt to overturn
an election I mean that's what this
really comes down to they don't like the
president they've never liked the
president they want to do impeach him
from day one they were hell-bent on
doing it and now oops they accidentally
did it they can't prove a case because
there isn't the case and they're putting
the whole country through this Tucker
and that's why it's time to bring this
to an end let's vote we've heard the
evidence they don't have a case let's
vote
so I know there's been some wrangling
over whether we're gonna have witnesses
and you know whether you're interested
that or not is another question but big
picture are you sensing there any
Republicans as of tonight who might vote
to convict well I could never can speak
for anybody else other than myself but I
will just say that my sense of the kind
the Republican Conference is that people
are ready to vote we have heard the
evidence we've admitted all of the
houses evidence into the record that
included testimony from 17 witnesses all
of that is before us so I just on this
record Tucker to be honest with you I
have a hard time imagining that somebody
would vote to convict the Republican
would vote to convict the evidence just
isn't there and I haven't heard anybody
say they think it is but we'll see it's
such a good point and it's not as if
there are a lot of United States
senators with long-standing
relationships with the president I mean
I presumably if there was evidence was
overwhelming the crime was committed you
wouldn't see a loss of some Republicans
wouldn't you oh I think yeah absolutely
I mean I think good look there's a lot
let's be honest here there's a lot of
senators on the Republican side who
don't like the president right so they
would be happy to vote against him
really some of them if they could find
grounds to but they just can't find any
grounds to because there aren't any and
the longer the house managers talk the
more obvious that because thank you for
your honesty center and thanks for
joining us in the middle of this chaos
appreciate it